gotta get him off me I'll be back the
moment I heard that out loud I'll be
back that was I think we're really
kicked in that we will make a terminator
films it was really hard to imagine
stepping into this I think what helped
me is also would help Amelia twitch was
playing Sarah which realize okay I'm not
doing that version this is a very
specific very different take this is a
very different kind of movie although
built out the same mythology you just go
and you don't look back it was just a
role that I jumped at the chance to play
she was an iconic figure that I grew up
watching and admiring so there were
there were lots of reasons as to why i
said yes i will i will take that
pressure on and i will try and do it
justice
an act to go I really want to do that
you know John Connor and tastic I loved
Eddie furlong in the second one I think
there's a whole chunk of John you
haven't seen and a person you need to
get to know on this night we take back
our world blowed up there's a little
pressure surrounding something that's so
iconic everything's changed I can't tell
you how much event at the end of it all
to have Cameron come forward and say
that he approved
you